this is the fight of our lives every
turn aid has an endgame hasn't been his
face you better not throw up on my ship
of ventures and gay 350g 13 tickets
available now how's it going everybody
it's Warren and we have a brand new
Avengers in-game clip it's short and
sweet but we do have some new footage to
break down specifically three main
scenes the two with Captain Marvel and
then the one scene with rocket and the
rest of the Avengers and the Bennet are
going into space I'll break them down in
this video but a quick reminder if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe I'm giving away a life-sized
Infinity Gauntlet and a painting of fan
OHS that glows in the dark I'll talk
more about the giveaway at the end so
the first thing we'll talk about is the
scene with rocket and the rest of the
Avengers on the Bennet are about to go
into space this is a scene that we've
heard about for a long time now it was
shown at the Disney shareholders meeting
and this was also included in the
footage that was shown at CinemaCon and
the footage that was shown to the press
on the Disney and Marvel Studios locked
obviously at this point in time with all
the footage that we've seen in
everything that we've heard the Avengers
definitely go into space very early on
in the movie to try and stop the noes
and this is clearly a comedic scene
right before because not all of them
have been to space before Natasha
Rhodey in Captain America all raised
their hands and rocket says you better
not throw up in my ship so that's just a
little bit of comic relief but let's
talk about these two scenes with Captain
Marvel and I think they're actually
shown in reverse order of how they'll be
in the movie
I think the second scene that they show
where it shows Captain Marvel flying off
into the sky when it's daylight outside
is what happens first in the movie I
think that this is her flying off into
space to go and try to save Tony and
nebula because the other scene that we
see with her in it she clearly looks
like she's outside of the Avengers
headquarters specifically it looks like
the same scene from the first trailer
that we got where all the Avengers are
walking outside at nighttime looking up
into the sky and this clip makes it look
like the Avengers are looking up at
Captain Marvel coming to the Avengers
headquarters but from the post-credits
scene of Captain Marvel we know that's
not the case we know that she arrives at
the Avengers headquarters when the
Avengers are trying to figure out what
Nick Fury's pager is so in this scene
that shows her outside of the Avengers
headquarters all lit up using
powers I think this is actually the
scene where Tony Stark and nebula get
back to earth with the help of Captain
Marvel because we do also have another
scene with Tony Stark
hugging pepper looks like the same
background and it's at night as well so
it appears like from what we've seen in
this new footage that captain is the one
that goes off into space and saves Tony
Stark and nebula and this footage here
with her outside of the avengers
headquarters lit up using her powers as
her returning from doing that and that's
it for all the new scenes like I said
it's a very short clip but did get some
new footage in it and what looks like to
be a pretty big discovery that Captain
Marvel is the one that's going to go
into outer space and save Tony Stark and
nebula but of course with the
researchers and the trailers you never
really know if the footage in the
trailers is gonna be in the movie but
still let me know what you think about
this new clip and let me know how
excited you are to see Avengers in game
in less than two weeks now let me know
in the comments down below and a
reminder about my giveaway I'm giving
away a life-size Infinity Gauntlet and a
glow-in-the-dark painting of fan oohs
bye globe I boat you can also find more
of his work at globe Ivo comm I'll put
the link in description down below to
enter the giveaway all you have to do is
be subscribed to my channel like the
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain and of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on everything relating to Avengers
in game and all things Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
[Music]